so is there any difference between
the goal of marathon or 100 miles would
you say
should i be prepping for 100 miles if
that's at all a possibility
the big difference is going to be like
you're dropping intensity significantly
by going
up to 100 miles versus the marathon so
the
maximum roving function i think is
actually going to feed into that maybe a
little bit better it's probably a little
closer
um depending on where i mean all it all
varies a bit because like people people
focus on specific distances and they'll
get
very efficient and very adapted to that
so like
the it kind of like it's what makes
running kind of messy where like you'll
get
for for example like the average person
can hit their like lactate threshold for
probably about like 60 minutes or
something like that whereas you get
these elite marathoners who've been
basically spending their entire life
preparing for a marathon race they can
push
almost up to their lactate threshold and
after lactate threshold for
almost like two hours so it gets a
little messy when you start
um looking at it from that lens but you
don't really have to worry about that
too much because you're not really
focusing on
being the best possible hundred miler or
the best possible marathoner you could
be you want
enough overall fitness that you can just
do either one of them
without absolute misery because you did
the couch to 100 miles
exactly so i think like for for 100
miles the biggest difference i think
given your contacts is just like the
more physical things you are doing
the better prepared you're going to be
for the 100 mile so it's almost
given your context i wouldn't say
irrelevant you want to be doing running
but you're going to be doing that once
you put it in your program it sounds
like it's going to be pretty
locked in um you're going to want to
also
like it if you view it this way it's
probably going to be more mentally
beneficial too where
hey today i did my run i did my
bodyweight exercises i did some
grappling practice
you know i spent three hours working out
today yeah if you think of it like that
then
you know you're you're moving your body
you're doing things that are
active for a good chunk of the day
especially relative to most people
so that's going to actually be very
helpful for you uh
the the problem or the the battle to get
over is gonna just be like
the you know you're gonna break down
physically running a hundred miles
and you're gonna break down physically
running a marathon too so
like the you might just have to push
through a little more discomfort
like from a physical standpoint compared
to be if you decided
i'm gonna do everything i can in these
next like
24 weeks to be able to run a full
hundred
a hundred miler would you say it's
physical or is it mental discomfort like
uh i mean isn't everything physically
uncomfortable like
what uh do you train for if you're
training for
the chaos of uh so it's not necessarily
miles it's the chaos of the unexpected
which might include 100 miles but it
might also include a thousand push-ups
yeah in my case so like you need a big
jack-of-all-trades it's what you need to
be yeah but also like building up the
confidence
or maybe not i don't know how do you
survive uh
a thousand push-ups it's a combination
of confidence that
you have to know that you can do that
kind of thing not necessarily the actual
number but like
doing crazy stuff and the
the second is probably okay the the base
strength
and endurance and also just the
practicing that process of not quitting
right i feel like that's one of the
things i really need to do in the
running space
it's like doing slightly unpleasant
things where i'm practicing that like
bringing my mind back and saying
nope uh i'm going to keep doing it and
part of the
running every day has that benefit
because some days you really don't want
to
don't feel like running and doing that
then you're practicing that muscle of um
of doing it anyway um i don't know if
there's something you can say in terms
of advice how to practice
the like doing something unpleasant
every day
yeah frequently yeah what i would do
with that is
i would try to make the unpleasant thing
be different from one day to the next if
you can so
the fear i would have with making
running unpleasant every time
would be it becomes like a negative
feedback loop
right in your physiologically
potentially as well as mentally where
if the entire running process is
miserable
you're going to be miserable when you
step on that starting line whether it's
a marathon or a hundred miles so
you've trained yourself then running
equals miserable well and here's the
thing like i mean if you look at just
like
here's where the literature says on
paper are like the
you know dozen workouts you should do in
a training plan
and this is how you should structure
them right down to the minute and you
just say like
i'm going to give everyone this schedule
and they're going to do this every time
rinse and repeat
my biggest concern with that approach is
you
are potentially putting them in a
position where the training is so boring
and so monotonous
that like if they hit a roadblock
mentally
they're going to fall apart very quick
because they've already exhausted
themselves mentally just trying to do
the same old interval every time
doing the same old you know workout and
it doesn't necessarily have to be like
one specific plan in its entirety could
just be like
like the the mix of things within it so
like rather than like
if i just said oh we're gonna do three
minute intervals through this entire
short interval process or two-minute
intervals or
four-minute intervals or 60-second
intervals you know by that
sixth week they might be so sick of that
they're not actually maximizing the
potential within that because there's no
flavor there
and and then they're also actually
getting less out of themselves than they
would if we just
got a little more creative and said okay
let's mix this up and let's do
uh you know four one minute intervals
then take a like a little bit of a break
and then we'll do three minute intervals
or at least changing it up from week to
week so that they have something
different showing up even though we're
addressing the same kind of
physiological adaptation
uh so like i think what you want to do
is you want to introduce the misery you
want to be able to test yourself to the
degree where like when you can recognize
these points if i don't want to be here
but i can do it push through it but
recognize that
like there's not necessarily going to be
one event that you want to lean on to
get that from because you won't want to
make that one event
so miserable that you don't want to do
it when it comes time for the challenge
so
if you can possibly say like okay on
tuesdays
the push-up workout i'm going to go 10
push-ups more than i want to i'm going
to get to that point where i'm like
there's no more and then i'm going to do
10 more
and you're going to make that one
miserable and then maybe on
uh you know thursdays you decide to do
like some of those sprints or something
at the end where
you do a few of them and you're like
okay this is where i'd be comfortable to
stop like well i'm going to do two more
of them because i know i don't want to
do two more of them
but mix that up so you're not so at
least you're getting enjoyment from some
of it
and not just getting complete disgust
from the entire process yeah
there's actually quite a lot of ways
that i can introduce misery
to the push-ups running get creative
including
um you know even just like stuff outside
of the running like taking
freezing cold showers those kinds of
things just introducing
random kind of chaos into the into the
system
um or having conversations with people
as an introvert
it's terrifying more podcasts
you